[Applaudissements]
j'y pense en me
mr
ces matières
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voit que ce tgv merci le ca merci le
cloud merci et là c'est du vrai faux
absolument incroyable des épreuves des
énigmes et puis bien sûr comme on dit si
de l'adar cas je peux vous dire quelque
chose je t'en prie magnifique c'est vrai
que j'ai c'est très très très très bon
point on peut pour garder ses combats et
des cours est-ce qu'on peut toucher
c'est pas pour ça qu'on va gagner
alors qu'est-ce qui a gagné madrid alors
écoutez ici quelque chose de particulier
vous allez pouvoir et des
téléspectateurs qui regardent le
programme pour le moment il y en a en
effet la possibilité donc si vous
réussissez l'épreuve les différentes
épreuves et si vous gagnez le mot code
de faire gagner un pack console de jeux
inédits à une personne sur twitter
c'est à dire je les cuis unités manière
croix de tous ces terres qui sont
normalement le 21 joueurs pour ça il
faut s'inscrire sur le compte twitter de
tpm paie donc n'hésitez pas à aller tout
de suite su en fait la grande rivière
il faut pour le trouvera d'accord on est
gay on dégaine bon d'accord on sera par
aastra ouais c'est nul mais on va le
faire
j'attends que touche-à-tout peut-être
est-ce qu'une première épreuve alors
bien sûr première épreuve et bader c
passe partout qui va nous s'est passé
pour lui dans mes mains mon truc je
m'adore
alors c'est collé pour avoir une
première clé et à la fin qui va donner
un sens à 10 ans les indices actions
je suis d'accord alors écoute bien il
nous faut quelqu'un d'élégant qui n'a
pas froid aux yeux
je pense que c'est toujours les faits tu
va donc devoir sur l'épreuve du
ras-le-bol chat deux minutes pour
trouver indices cachés dans un football
non c'est à saint chély c'est kelly ça
alors c'est ça qu'il s'était tu n'a le
droit tu dois trouver dans les bols wen
a dit la nasa
il est tout petit laid et emma
publiquement taboue jonathan wes howard
va bien tu vas dans les bols d'accord
qui ont souvent un téléspectateur
voilà là bas nos frontières à l'adisq
les éditrices une minute 45 à l'habitude
de manger et aux incessants devient
assez chic à la fois qu'elle regarde la
whey yoboki l'habitude de faire la fête
et dans l'écouté
[Applaudissements]
hyper bien alors on donne alors lundi
s'il donne à olivier minne alors là
disent parce que tout à leur faudra
trouver un mot voilà qui va faire gagner
un téléspectateur extrême et express ex
commencé à réfléchir à ce que le mot
code pourrait être avec ce premier
indice de tout comme cet indice nous qui
ont tout de suite à l'équilibré l'an
passé pas de savoir tout balle est allée
à l'italie
[Applaudissements]
alors ça c'est déjà la jungle ce n'est
pas rien parce que pour cette jungle
nous allons avoir besoin d'un couple de
personnes talentueuses
d'accord je pense qu'il s'agit de cyril
et de mathieu cinéma tursan cyril et
mathieu a marqué ce film attention cette
cellule vous trouverez plusieurs papiers
mais il n'y en a qu'un seul sur lequel
est écrit lundi stocker un des leurs
d'accord il commençait faut toujours un
le mieux c'est au ramasser le bâtir soit
pour pas louper la martinique vous sera
utile à alors c'est pas alors on dit que
c'est pas cette cellule cette attitude
je crois mais c'est que les élèves
soient de la fri tard c'est isabelle
sicard s'est qu'isabelle et elle va
devoir le faire ce voyage le père qu'il
faut évidemment c'est le père qu'il faut
être sévères' de frapper la fois que
c'est pour toi tu dois d'en résoudre une
énigme
tu dois résoudre une énigme en effet
mais voilà c'est tout la pièce
condamnée on a mis ça c'est des trucs à
prout sais pas si willy fait ça tout le
temps celles exerçant terriblement fort
sinon ne t'approche pas c'est toxique à
waldhambach on va écouter l'énigme
mauvais
[Musique]
on peu avant le retour sécurisé à des
fins de retour ça pourrait bien pâle on
l'a fait on sent qu il s'apprêtait
pourtant pas voir le son la
mais jules petit les cruise avait deux
articles pour votre aîné écouter pour
avoir la 10 il est fait de maïs de
seigle et de bli atari est également un
valet son nom évoque aussi un insecte
rayé et enfin isabelle de son arôme
nombreux ce sens c'est quoi les alliés
compris aux meublés débile c'est facile
connaissant merde il se trouvait lundi
un important volet fier non rappelle ne
sert à rien d'aller à paris palais
brogniart et non des grognards non les
palets palais royal
elle est bien là n'est pas un coupé
alors c'était quoi mais je suis alors
dit je veux pas les pourboires
mais merde je sais pas ce que c'est il
va le dire aux téléspectateurs les
insectes oreiller gourmand mais le
bourdon on y va et si possible
méo et
horner partie là c'est la jungle et la
série les matchs à rasséréner matures
après cyril et mathieu ont la garde
donc je voulais ya dans cette cellule
des papiers à foison il faut trouver sur
le pont papier lundi ce qui vous servira
tout à l'heure avant le mot corps
d'accord que tout s'est ramassé réserver
ses billets faut aller comme ça c'est ou
alors ça me donne un autre nom n'ont
jamais dit non tu avec moi je suis resté
dix non non
je peux pas la règle tantôt je te lèves
tu attends t'es dur est à côté
non y'a juste à côté c'est que 2006 les
femmes se plaignent de voir tu peux pas
dire ça je ne prends pas la tête je te
dis on peut tout à l'heure tu vas d'art
chocolat et ça pour la même mission
non non ce n'est pas ça qui m'a dit je
te fais rien je fais toi je t'ai fait
bon vivre et où je vais payer mais qui
va nous tomber dessus non [ __ ] mais
bel et bien mais tu me fait repousser le
jure sur ma vie tu manques tu mens pu
retoucher un an je te prendre les
articles obligés à l'épreuve et la
callas pour dire que deviens tu as
tourlaville à droite mais là là là et
bien évidemment fermé mais je veux
passer là je fais il s'appelle venir
aussi bas shabelle et mathieu et javel
s'est beaucoup plaint mais jamais avec
sa morale toiture est en retrait lors
des papilles
je déteste jeudi à paris je faisais
c'était ça je ne dépense que ça c'était
facile store qui dit alors qu'il est
fidèle idée aussi des orchidées bien
commencé à infléchir michael streeter
extrait orchidées
on part tout de suite maintenant vers
l'épreuve suivante pas partout et moi
qui vais c'est moi qui la prends le
litre est salée pendant on y va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois qu'elles sont
c'est beau
ça s'est passé dimanche
alors il mort cela forcément ça qu'on
est éreinté et nous reste combien
d'épreuves et noir est de 2 1 des siens
merci passe partout passe pas par tout
média c'est le défi des chaises blanches
71 ci dessous des lois en chine ça c'est
avec benjamin on le sait il nous faut
quelqu'un de costaud
[Musique]
d'habitude c'est choisir entre eux n'est
pas libre souhaitant donner votre film
milk je pense qu'on va passer
directement à l'épreuve de chance alors
regardez bien ces mains dans une de mes
mains se cache une pierre blanche à
gauche alors il
concentrez-vous bien est-ce que vous
allez choisir la main numéro ou deux non
il ya quelques de foot que de la douceur
celle-ci rose blanche ou la main numéro
un
bravo vous avez gagné lundi
[Rires]
même la gauche l'avaient extrait booth
khider qui devrait présenter dans le
tapis volant on s'y passe pas partout
nos relations
ici les voilà c'est je crois que c'est
bon on arrête ou mathieu mathieu comme
il n'a pas fait de blessé at elle dit
ces bonnes idées
si oui c'est pour toi ça alors il faut
que tu te mettes pieds nus dans l'intrus
chloé pieds nus relais faire maintenant
il faut dû répondre à une énigme posée
par magic
ouais c'est magique une créature un peu
pratique d'ailleurs que l'on retrouvait
dans fort boyard cet été totalement
exactement comme la mamie non c'est quoi
un aléa voies sur trois de ses parcs et
lieux emmerdes
j'ai dis va te faire passer l'épreuve
bonnes réponses à mes questions de
culture médias et vous aurez la vie
[Musique]
la piste n'est pas convenable aux
[ __ ] milieu des programmes télévisés
a révélé jeudi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
votre nom est victor hugo quel est le
prénom de la mère de cosette et demi
d'ouverture autres car mon patron qui
vous savez non pas du tout dans quelle
ville déserte maritie et la capitale des
parfums être à part des militants
cette chorale y'a combien y at-il de
maria dans la galerie martine à 13
pas du tout trois complété les deux
bandes dessinées tintin qui chante aïcha
dont 85 avec quel poids de quel animal
tu l'as tu es posible qu'il aurait
reçues il s'engage mais n'ont pas dit ce
garçon souffre voilà canada
non
un dispositif aurait effectivement il ya
des morts alors c'est gagné
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] gp9
la ligne a est super c'est un espèce de
connard avec une veste en dessous passé
doit cette enquête madagascar c'est
qu'elle être derrière les chiens j'ai
trouvé c'est une famille alors au final
ça du trésor on doit les allées on doit
encore être le mot vanille blessure
gagner à une loterie à l'ennemi chacun
est levée
non mais là les îles mettez-vous dessus
ça c'est si on n'a pas de place
on est passé allez-y bonera levée
mettez-vous dessus suisse à l'ol adieu
la presse que ces vanille est-ce que
c'est bas n'y aura pas qu'un
téléspectateur qui peut gagner un cadeau
magnifique sac à main doit de briques je
le rappelle en effet il s'agit donc de
la toute nouvelle console de jeu qui
sera normalement près de cas partir du
21 juin
je pars mahdi un micro
ce jeu c'était r attention que manny est
le bon mon statut peut pousser ce
plateau dans le savoir regarder en
direction du fort tous ça marche pas ce
n'est pas son intention de tuer
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais